in addition to some of the bills we
already talked about that Florida has
passed relating to trans people and
don't say gay and so on and so forth
there was one that I just didn't get the
opportunity to talk about on the show in
fact I think much of the the discussion
around it happened when I was when I was
away the Florida legislature has
ultimately passed this very extreme
anti-trans bathroom bill as well as a
ban on gender affirming care and the
details of the bills are all of the
things that you would imagine it would
penalize providers by putting criminal
penalties when a gender affirming care
is given in certain situations it would
take licenses away from providers it
would prohibit Medicare from covering
gender affirming care for Trans youth or
adults it prohibits public funds it's
sort of like the full package that
they've tried and sometimes done on
abortion over the last 20 years going in
the direction of trans now there's a
particular detail about the debate that
I want to look at with you this is not
new this happened
um this happened a couple weeks ago but
it's just an extraordinary reminder of
the insanity that is taking place in
Florida I'm going to play a clip for you
here of Republic Florida Republican uh
representative Webster Barnaby
who said during a completely Bonkers
rant debating HB 1521 which is the bill
that we're talking about here
criminalizing trans people for using
restrooms that correspond to their
gender identity all these different
things I mentioned
he refers to trans people as mutants
demons and imps reminiscent of sci-fi
characters including X-Men if you can
imagine listen to listen to what's
happening in Florida I'm looking at
society today yeah and it's like I'm
watching an X-Men movie okay with
people that when you watch the X-Men
movies for Marvel Comics
it's like we have mutants
living among us on planet Earth ugh
and you know
some people don't like that but that's a
fact it's not we have people that live
among us today on planet Earth
that
are happy
to display themselves
as if they were mutants from another
planet this is some of the most vile and
disgusting language that has been used
by elected officials during hearings on
this issue these issues
this is the planet Earth
where God created men male and women
female wow I'm a proud Christian ah oh I
didn't real oh he's he's a proud
Christian oh well oh so then we have to
accept any completely unhinged hateful
rant from him I'm sure Conservative
Republican
I'm not on the fence
there is so much darkness in our world
today
so much evil in our world today
and so many people who are afraid to
address the evil the dysphoria the
dysfunction
I'm not afraid to address the dysphoria
or the dysfunction
the Lord rebuke you Satan exactly what
you would expect to hear during a
discussion of law in a civil government
that separates church and state would be
for an elected official to rebuke Satan
as part of his political philosophy
completely normal stuff and all of your
demons and all of your imps who come and
parade before us
that's right I called you demons and
imps who come and parade before us
and pretend that you are part of this
world right
so I'm I'm saying my righteous
indignation is stirred I am sick and
tired of this we are too
we I'm not going to put up with it
you can test me and try to take me on
but I promise you I'll win every time
this is the
uh DeSantis agenda with
sort of a violent Christianity laced
through it
you mix it up spit it out and this is
what you get now as a matter of just you
know noting if you're listening
um the the distinguished gentleman
Barnaby happens to be black and so we
have uh an individual from a
historically marginalized group in
society marginalizing
another marginalized group from society
which just really warms the heart
doesn't it the bill ultimately did pass
and this is an example of what some
Floridians have
um representing them this is the
ideology that we see really really
tragic sad stuff
yet another Donald Trump arrest now
appears to be almost certain this summer
let me explain the we've been seeing
some of this news for a bit now
it now seems pretty clear Vice news
reports Trump's next criminal charge is
practically on the calendar let me
explain
former this is from the article former
president Donald Trump's second criminal
indictment looks all but certain to go
down this summer you could even mark it
on your calendar between June 11 I'm
sorry July 11 and September 1st why
those dates because Fulton County
district attorney fani Willis Fanny
Willis no matter how I pronounce it
someone writes to me saying I'm saying
it wrong Fannie Willis has formally
asked local officials to beef up
security during that window when she
plans to announce charging decisions in
her long-running investigation of
Trump's attempt to reverse his 2020
election defeat in Georgia
she wouldn't need all that extra
security if she weren't planning to go
after Trump himself former prosecutors
and legal experts say Titus Nichols an
Atlanta area defense attorney and former
prosecutor said quote The Fulton DA's
letter makes it almost certain that
Trump is getting indicted there is no
reason to send something in writing no
other reason to the sheriff so let me
tell you what this is all about
um several weeks ago uh Fannie Willis's
office did send a letter to the sheriff
indicating requesting additional
security uh during this next period uh
that will contain whatever decisions are
made with regard to Trump and Georgia
that period of time is July 11 to
September 1. and as former prosecutors
lawyers others are saying and it's just
casual observers of this are saying why
would she make that request were it not
because there is going to be a decision
made to arrest Donald Trump and that
there was going to be a similar
um circumstance that plays out in
Georgia as what we saw in New York City
I think that that's pretty likely you
know the if we want to make a sort of
differential diagnosis of the facts you
could say well in order to not show her
hand early
she is requesting the extra security
regardless on the idea that there might
be agitated people whether or not Trump
is charged or something along those
lines maybe like maybe she says well if
I charge Trump his supporters will be
furious and they might show up and be
violent and if I announce I'm not
charging Trump people who want him
charged will show up and be violent the
reason that's hard to believe is we've
seen no evidence there's no reason to
believe or fear that people who think
Trump should be charged are going to
show up and be violent if he isn't
charged we just I just don't there's no
reason to think that that would happen
so I do think the most likely scenario
is Trump is going to be charged in
Georgia this is not going to impact his
existing supporters very much in all
likelihood the question is is it going
to impact Trump's ability to be out and
campaigning if now with another arrest
another indictment another pending trial
if this all starts to get in the way of
trump being able to just go and campaign
it may start to make him an unappealing
candidate the Counterpoint to that is
there absolutely are Mega people on the
right on the Republican uh in the
Republican voting roles who will
actually be energized if Trump is
arrested again they will feel that he is
being scapegoated they will feel that he
is being you know and remember the key
word is feel they will feel that he is
being targeted for political reasons
rather than he did things no former
president has ever ever done the Georgia
case in particular is interesting
because it is arguably where the the
most serious and most relevant charges
may come from and there are other
prominent Republicans that are wrapped
up and Tangled in the Georgia mess
Lindsey Graham and so many others it is
not yet clear even whether or not Trump
is charged and it looks like he will be
that may not be the full list there may
be even more Republicans charged the
fake elector scheme required dozens of
Highly placed people so this could
actually be a major major takedown of a
number of conservative figures speaking
legally of course and as always you all
know I am for Law and Order and I
actually am for Law and Order if there
is no evidence against someone they
should not be charged I don't want
anybody charged for political reasons
reasons of Retribution revenge or
whatever the case may be if there is no
evidence then do not charge people what
I want is for the justice system and for
uh the investigations to happen
unfettered unconstrained by political
meddling or whatever the case may be
look at the evidence compare it to the
laws and then make a charging decision
that should apply to Trump
it should apply to Biden Hunter Biden
Hillary Obama people who work uh locally
people who dog walkers McDonald's
employees this should be the standard
that is always applied and I am
consistently for that so the news is
almost certainly Trump's getting
arrested again if and when it happens we
will have it for you it is the Friday
show in the sense that it's Friday and
this is the show we will take a very
quick break and continue right after
this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show continues to be an
audience supported program what that
means is there's no major corporate
funder of our show that comes with a lot
of great benefits including that I just
decide what's on the show and no one can
coerce me or convince me to talk or not
talk about whatever the downside is we
do depend on your support to do what we
do but we have a great system for that
called membership you can sign up at
joinpakman.com it takes mere seconds and
you can use the coupon code 24 starts
now if you'd like to get a discount off
of the cost of your membership sign up
at joinpakman.com let's get to the
phones which we do via Discord on the
Friday show davidpackman.com
Discord join the Discord it's free it's
a good time but let's hear from some
people at davidpackman.com Discord see
what is on people's minds let's go for
first to Nelson from Bethlehem Nelson
welcome to the David packman show
Nelson welcome to the program
oh I apologize David I had pushed a
talking thank you for taking me first
um I actually just had one question and
I wanted to know if I could get your
thoughts on some breaking news sure
um what is your opinion on the United
States government uh taking out the
mandates today for the um
International Air
to covert vaccine
the U.S took that out for incoming
travelers from other countries
yes and federal employees and the such
no longer have to be coveted vaccinated
I saw that and I was really surprised I
thought it was supposed to be a
permanent thing um uh I think the White
House put out a thing on it you can see
it I believe that it all ends on May
11th yeah let's see I've actually got it
here so we can be precise U.S covid-19
travel restrictions to be lifted May
11th will be the last day for multiple
restrictions including that
International Air visitors be fully
vaccinated listen I don't know what my
medical opinion on it is I can tell you
that politically I get why it's been
done why it is being done and I also you
know if we are to believe that at this
point in time the vaccine doesn't
prevent transmission
um then in a sense I get it right it's
sort of if you want to protect yourself
from becoming seriously ill you get
yourself vaccinated but if it doesn't
reduce transmission then why does
everybody need to be required to be
vaccinated I think the risk of it is in
an Ideal World Nelson
at some point we will have a coveted
vaccine that does prevent transmission
and at that point no longer having the
tool of requiring it could be a missed
opportunity to actually reduce
transmission of the virus but that's a
future looking question
yep oh well I completely agree David
well thank you for having me on First
and um shout out to my good friend soft
gentleman he's also listening but he
can't call in right now so thanks David
have a great day Nelson from Bethlehem
very powerful stuff
um what was that the soft something I
don't know what that is I don't know if
that's a listener of mine let's go next
to Will from North Carolina will from
North Carolina Welcome to the program
what's on your mind
hello uh I know that your focus is
largely electoral politics but I was
wondering if you have any comment on
them
some means of uh affecting Progressive
political change outside of electoralism
like maybe uh labor organizing or a
mutual Aid in your community just any
thoughts you have on that sure I think
that if all we're doing is voting and
then tuning out for four or two years
that is a huge missed opportunity and
this is unfortunately you know the right
understands this will that's the thing
the right understands we're going to
raise hell at school board meetings and
we're going to try to get involved in
Municipal uh uh requirements and you
know this recent idea of let's ban trans
people from dressing in line with their
gender identity that they're they're the
Department of Agriculture I guess in
Texas is trying to put that in place the
right knows how to get involved in all
of this other stuff and I think it's
critically important that the left do it
as well and whether it's again School
Board city councils
um events in communities all of these
things dealing with police policy right
get making yourself heard uh when there
is the possibility of changing police
policy within a municipality we've got
to be doing all of these things and
importantly you know Neil Postman wrote
about this okay we vote
and then we watch all this news about
Russia and Ukraine as interesting as it
is and as as important as what's going
on in Russia and Ukraine is in affecting
people's lives there
what are you or you are you going to do
about the situation in Russia Ukraine
and shouldn't we redirect some of the
time that we're focused on issues that
we will never impact shouldn't we
redirect some of that time on our local
communities so I'm with you a hundred
percent
all right well thank you David have a
great day all right will from North
Carolina great to hear from you let's go
next to
Deshawn from Atlanta Georgia DeSean
welcome to the program
DeSean please
hello
how are you doing today I'm doing well
good good
um I had two quick questions for you
sure
um so one uh how is your field or
outlook on that kid that got sent home
for having a shirt that said there's
only two genders I don't know where that
happened where did that happen it was it
I I don't know I I saw on Instagram some
some kid he he wore a shirt to school
and people were saying that they felt
unsafe and that he was he was being like
a distraction or something what what's
your opinion so here it is seventh
grader sent home for wearing t-shirt
that said there are only two genders
this is a 12 year old and
um we don't have to say the kid's name
was removed from gym class and told to
take off his shirt because people were
complaining it was making them feel
unsafe he refused they called his father
his father ended up having to pick him
up
um
listen I I don't I don't know how I feel
about this you know on the one hand how
involved do we want to get in how kids
dress at public schools with no dress
code obviously they can't wear things
that are obscene I guess would be the
law the question is is that an obscene
shirt
uh I agree that it could be a shirt that
is deeply a troubling and offensive to
people is it obscene I don't know so I'm
not sure about the legal basis wait wait
wait I I have a question how what's
what's uh what's what's what's the
what's the problem with it though you
said that you said that there was
something wrong with wearing well it's
not that I said that there's something
wrong but like let I'll give you a
scenario right imagine that you are a
trans person right you were you're
biologically male but you are trans you
identify as female and you are starting
to you know dress and Style Yourself the
way women traditionally do in modern
society I could see how seeing that
shirt is going to cause you uh Stress
and Anxiety and potentially make you
feel unsafe because it's a very like
listen I'll give you an opinion but it's
gonna be fat though I mean he he got
sentenced he got sent home for wearing a
t-shirt that says right well hold on a
second I can't you can't nothing wrong
with that that's just his that's just
his you know what I'm saying hold on a
second Sean but let's wait a second
right let's just wait a second hold on
to Sean your switch you're you're
jumping between saying the shirt is a
fact versus people's rights let's pick
one of these things to focus on right
because you're jumping all around all
right let's
let's all right so let's let's
do a scenario okay yeah let's say I go
to school and and I go to school and it
says I'll wear a shirt that says there's
only boy and girl
all right what tell me if tell me if
that's a legitimate reason for me to get
sent home
yeah I'm I'm I don't know that it is a
legitimate reason to be sent home it
doesn't be like well hold up to Sean
you're not even letting me talk though
no I'm letting you talk bro but I'm just
I'm just trying to get you know what I'm
saying no but every three words you're
interrupting me here's the the thing I'm
struggling with uh I am close to a free
speech absolutist in that I really don't
want to be restricting the speech of
individuals unless there's like a very
clear reason to do so and when we talk
about clothes being worn in school my
tendency would be to say let's let's not
get involved in schools making those
decisions I'm thinking of let's just
think about another shirt that someone
could wear right like I'm a Jewish
person imagine that I'm 12 and someone
wears a shirt to school that says all
non-christians are going to hell it's
certainly not an illegal shirt but as a
Jewish person I'm gonna see that and say
wow that's a lot of damn hostility
towards me based on my identity does
this person know my Identity or not am I
safe is this going to be a comfortable
learning environment so you know DeSean
if you listen to my show you know I'm
not big on trigger warnings or any of
this college being a safe space thing
but I'm struggling with what should be
allowed in a middle school for shirts I
don't know the answer
all right I mean that that's that's a
reasonable that's a reasonable answer
would you can I ask you a question
Desean
oh yes sir go ahead yo I mean I thought
I was asking a question but yeah go
ahead well you know we can both ask
questions that's the beautiful thing
about Independent Media
um would you agree separate now from
biological sex do you agree that people
Express gender on a spectrum I'm not
asking your opinion of whether it's good
or bad do you just agree that people
Express their gender I agree I agree
that if you have a certain belief of
biology and your science stands on it
and you have that sort of belief then
you can stand by it you can stand by
what
on biology no but let me ask you can I
rephrase the questions you can't because
there ain't no Spectrum on biology I'm
not that wasn't my question Sean is it
okay if I just restate my question a
different way and then you can answer it
or not
okay but I have a second question that I
I didn't I didn't ask it because let's
get to that in a second let me just
first just to make me feel good flatter
me let me ask my question one more time
okay
colliding you what what you mean by that
bro okay
okay go ahead indulge is maybe what I
mean would you agree that The Rock
Dwayne The Rock Johnson and the fashion
designer Isaac Mizrahi are both
biologically male would you agree with
that
I mean the rock is a man and whoever I
don't know the other person but if
they're a God then yeah then they're a
man okay would you also agree that
despite both being biological men they
express their gender very differently
where the rock expresses significantly
more masculinity while Isaac Mizrahi
expresses more what we might associate
with femininity would you agree with
that
e okay yes yes but but listen No but
hold on to Sean hold on hold on identity
no but hold on I'm not saying anything
about biologics hold on what's the
difference between expressing and what
you are but I'm all I'm asking you is
you can you can express yourself all you
want see the rock can express itself as
as uh a dress wearing yes
now that you're swearing we're gonna
have to bleep so we can't just please
don't oh all I'm saying to Sean is all
I'm saying is my question was do you
agree do you agree that gender is
expressed on a spectrum and you agreed
with the example I just gave that that's
true I'm not pushing any other belief on
you other than that
boo what's your what's your idea on a
spectrum though I don't understand that
biological Men Express different levels
of masculinity and femininity in their
expression and so do biological women
that's all that's all I'm saying you
agree that gender is expressed on a
spectrum
well people Express their gender in
different ways I mean you can say you
can say you're a man but then on the
other hand you can act like you're like
you're not a man you know what I'm
saying all right I think I got it all
right real quick what was your other
question to Sean
and um oh yeah this was this was
actually a very very important question
okay
what do you think about
women
trans women going into sports playing
against other women
okay I've addressed this a thousand
times I think in a lot of sports it
doesn't matter I think we do need to
figure out well there are certain Sports
where physical strength is not the uh
sort of determining factor of Advantage
but I agree that we need to figure out
in certain Sports how to handle that I
don't know the answer I think it's a
tough question and I don't have an
answer I think it does have to be
figured out it that it is it is actually
because you know how there's the WNBA
and there's the NBA like there's a
there's a reason yeah but I'd agree with
you DeSean I'd agree with you on
basketball I'm agreeing with you on
basketball I would agree with you I
don't I don't know what we do it seems
we need to figure that out is it now is
it now that we have to make a transport
sort of League thing like is this what
we're gonna have to do like do you
understand what I'm saying I do that's
an idea that's been playing against
women manhandling women you know what
I'm saying that's just ridiculous all
right DeSean thank you so much there's
DeSean from Atlanta he's acting like my
views on these issues are totally
different from what they are like yeah
we gotta figure that out I mean in some
sports I'm not sure what you do we've
talked about do you have to look at
um does there have to be some medical
consensus about whether I don't know in
some sports what we do I'm not
pretending that we've solved that uh so
there's no reason to you know put
pretend like my view is something other
than what it is let's go to David from
Philadelphia David from Philadelphia
what's going on today
I'm sorry I know you don't I don't do
that sorry
um
can you hear me yes I can
first off I just want to say I listened
to that whole Deshawn thing
um I disagree with everything he's
saying
he's full of it he's just like
live your life the way you want you know
if you identify as a woman it makes no
never mind to me if you identify as a
man makes no never mind to me
there so anyway
I keep hearing you talk about how
conservatives and magas they only
subscribe to their principles when it's
convenient for them and drop it uh once
it's inconvenient correct right well in
with some with some principles yes
I'd I'd say all of them when it comes to
uh you know when it comes to capitalism
free market or with free speech or with
limited government like all of them you
know once uh it's inconvenient they drop
it okay yeah I mean with a lot of those
issues you're absolutely right yeah so
if we take that to its conclusion
would you say the only principle these
magas are consistent with is a white
supremacist
patriarchy where rich old white men are
on top and everybody else and everything
else is exploited exiled or eliminated
while the rich old white men just
consolidate and get as much power and
money as possible listen that's
absolutely the case for some parts of
the American right wing but not for all
of it and I don't think we gain anything
or Advance our cause by painting the
entire modern American right wing as a
white Supreme with a white supremacist
brush so I think you're correct that the
vast majority of the white supremacists
who want to put white Christian men at
the top of a hierarchy are voting more
for Republicans than Democrats that I
agree with but saying that that's what
the Republican party with the entire
right wing is at this point I don't
think it's productive nor is it
completely accurate
okay I I appreciate that also let me
apologize for sounding a little
pretentious I've been doing a thousand
things at once and once I was trying to
get all this out there so it kind of
sounds a little I don't know combative
thank you I appreciate that I watch your
show all or listen to your show all the
time and uh you're one of the
better
um one of the better uh podcasters out
there you're very um very pragmatic you
believe in one thing but you understand
the reality of the situation and I
appreciate that and like not to knock
The Young Turks or uh Baron College
cousins but they're very uh you know why
isn't this the way it's supposed to be
and I appreciate that you understand why
stuff isn't the way it's supposed to be
even though you wish stuff would be the
way it would be that way all right David
from Philadelphia very much appreciate
the call let's take a very quick break
if you're holding on hold on because
we're going right back to the phones in
a moment
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's hear from a few more people we
take calls via Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord let's go to Skyler in New York
Skyler welcome to the program uh what is
on your mind today
hey David how's my audio it's beautiful
great so um I wanted to ask you about
the ongoing uh battle between Disney and
Ron DeSantis yes um on one hand I do
tend to agree that Disney as a
corporation is way too powerful and the
idea that they can basically self-govern
can be a bit of a red flag and you know
generally there are a lot of other
aspects about Disney that are damaging
to the free market to labor to the
environment uh
I'm really enjoying how Disney continues
to humiliate the Santos and the amount
of elves that they keep handing him now
I don't really think DeSantis is taking
some sort of principled stance in this
whole bottle it's uh this whole battle
it's obviously just cultural and over
the don't say gay stuff and Disney
allegedly being woke but I'm curious
David where do you fall in this whole
battle I think that I share your
concerns with the idea that a
corporation can essentially work as a
self-governing entity I don't like that
I think it's not a power that should be
delegated to corporations and and with
that I agree 100
I do believe that DeSantis and this
anti-woke movement has overplayed its
hand as it applies to Disney and more
generally uh there's polling that now
I've discussed a number of times that
shows that the majority of the American
public it's not a huge majority but it
is a majority actually falls on the woke
rather than the anti-woke side on a lot
of these different issues including
trans LGBT Etc so so I believe that it
is a bad strategic decision for DeSantis
in Florida to Target
uh Disney not only over issues where the
the majority of the country is actually
with Disney but also because Disney is
so beloved you know I hate theme parks
but a lot of people love them and people
like the Disney characters and the
movies and all that it seems like a bad
uh decision to pick a fight with Disney
tactically as well
yeah and you know my biggest like I
don't know if it's a concern or just
observation is is obviously the
continued escalation over you know what
being anti-woke actually means
um you know I I don't know where it ends
like at this point we're having a whole
war on like Western society and culture
um whether it's education whether it's
Medical Science whether it's you know
culture and religion it just I I don't
know like where the end point is so let
me address that if you ask people on the
right they would say the anti-wokness
ends when we defeat wokeness my view is
that's never going to happen because the
country has become more and more woke I
mean when you if we think about wokeness
as sort of like enlightened left-wing
ideas the country keeps moving more and
more in that direction so I think
anti-wokness ends as those ideas become
less and less common
and when Republicans realize they're not
going to win with anti-wokness then
they'll move on to the next thing
sort of corporate wokeness that gets you
know derided by the right by big
corporations tends to typically only
exist in the social sense and that a lot
of times this corporate wokeness doesn't
really trickle down to like improve
Progressive progressivism around labor
or equitability 100 and that's because
for a lot of these corporations they're
just taking the view they determine to
be more socially palatable and it's
because that's what's most profitable
much for taking my call David all right
thank you great to hear from you there's
Skyler in New York with a very uh
interesting and important issues being
being brought up why don't we go next to
I hope I pronounced this correctly is it
tiku in Los Angeles California tiku
tiku welcome to the program please
accept the invitation to join
uh I'm here welcome what's on your mind
today
uh so I have been uh listening for quite
some time uh since uh last year and uh
I've noticed that a lot of the callers
uh tend to be men and I was wondering if
just like by way of data or insights
from being in the industry if you have
any uh Insight on why that might be yeah
shows like mine The Young Turks and
others have significantly larger male
audiences than they do female audiences
it's in all of the demographics it
applies to all of our shows even shows
like this with female co-hosts still
have overwhelmingly male audiences and
uh that's reflected in the callers I
think and and part of it is
what what the demographic data seemed to
show is that women are less likely to
get political analysis from online
left-wing Independent Media shows than
men are
interesting yeah okay uh and then uh a
final question just for you as a media
professional I wanted to hear kind of
even though this is sort of politics
adjacent uh your take on uh the strikes
that are happening
the late night writers right well listen
we we actually talked about this on the
award-winning and world famous bonus
show earlier in the week
um the the thing about the the strikes
is
the demands are obviously they're they
were not able to come to an agreement
over salary but it's really more
complicated than that and so much of the
uh money being made on these programs is
now coming on the back end through
archives and streaming and asynchronous
viewing and writers don't typically have
a provision in their contract that
compensates them for that so they are
saying now that the initial audience
that watches it live on TV is only a
fraction of the total audience since we
don't get any of the back end we need
more money up front I think that's a
totally legitimate claim it's a reality
about the changing media landscape so I
think they're they're completely uh uh
correct in uh their desire to be paid
more upfront
great well thanks for taking my call I
also don't watch any of those shows so
it really doesn't bother me if they're
off the air well there you go all right
tiku thank you I appreciate the call
sure what is is that finish is that a
Finnish name
uh no uh it's a name my mom made up
because it's easier for Americans to say
than my actual name oh okay all right
fair enough all right do you from Los
Angeles Crystal Clear thank you very
much appreciate that why don't we go
next to Patrick from Vancouver Patrick
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hello David uh how are you sir I'm
coming to you with tears in my eyes
enough to flush the toilet 10 to 15
times
very good
uh I am wondering about today about your
opinion about um ESG investing
well I mean so won't ESG investing for
people who don't know is investing that
takes into account the environmental and
social impact of the companies that you
are investing in
um generally speaking you know there's
two views on this one view is if you
focus on ESG
you're going to get an inferior return
because the most profitable companies
may not adhere to whatever is sort of
like En Vogue at the time in terms of
adhering to environmental and social
issues so it's a perfectly fine way to
invest but you're just going to have a
lower return the the increasing
Counterpoint is that over the medium to
long term the most profitable companies
will be the ones that are
environmentally and socially conscious
so that actually it's the best of both
worlds you're doing a good thing morally
and ethically and you're also going to
get the highest return honestly my view
on this is not a morality view it's
informed my but my by My Views generally
on investing which is I don't think I'm
good at picking stocks I don't think
most people are good at picking stocks
I'm going to invest in the broadest
index that I can
ESG index funds but like the problem is
like their management fees are
significantly higher the high management
fees but my view on this Patrick is if
over time
the core all companies in in a country
are going to move more in the direction
of stricter environmental and social
standards by investing in the broadest
possible Index Fund over time I'll get
more exposure to that ESG aspect anyway
okay
so it just it'll just the market the
market like for like you know for
something like I don't know an S P 500
Index it'll just adjust over time I
would go even much broader I I would go
with a total stock market index yeah
okay
so like I shouldn't feel bad about say
investing currently right now in a in
like you know a total stock market
that's a different question whether you
should feel bad or not I can't tell you
maybe you do feel I mean listen you know
Noam Chomsky was confronted a few years
ago and they said you know you make all
these criticisms about corporations and
all these different things the
environment and social responsibility
but then you've got your retirement
money in the same index funds everybody
uses and chomsky's response was
basically like listen I'm an activist
for the things that I believe are right
but at the end of the day am I going to
keep my money under my mattress that
doesn't make any sense there are
obviously more options now than just
mattress or oil stocks but uh you know
that's chomsky's View
okay thank you very much sir all right
my friend thank you very much for the
call uh always
um always great to hear from our friends
to the north I'll be back in Canada soon
it'll be extraordinarily exciting I'm
sure let's go next to Thomas from
Vietnam what time is it in Vietnam it
must be is it like 2 A.M or something
like that or I don't even know what time
it is there
Thomas please unmute yourself so you can
tell me what time it is
no boy
Thomas yourself music there you go
hey uh it's almost midnight here almost
midnight to uh yeah 10 to 12.
I love it what's going on today
um all right so we've
um it's Joe Biden uh going to join the
race and for the uh election who do you
think is going to be the next
um nominee for the uh
Democratic party I believe it will be
Joe Biden
uh yeah but who who who would challenge
uh Joe body on on a primary would be the
most likely uh candidate do you think to
to win or to challenge
uh to challenge Joe Biden on the on the
primary for the Democrats I mean I think
it's the people that are currently
running it's Marianne Williamson and
Bobby Kennedy Jr I it doesn't seem like
there's a big appetite from serious
Democratic contenders to challenge Joe
Biden I don't think we're going to see
that
right but uh do things with who would
you know be posting the the biggest
challenge to Joe Biden at the moment oh
if they ran who might really be able to
challenge him in a serious way right
yeah yeah that's what I meant you know
there I have two views on this one view
is
another Center left Democrat who's just
younger and more energizing but who
isn't too far left would do best so like
that would be an argument for like Gavin
Newsom if Gavin Newsom challenged Joe
Biden it's someone who's not very far to
Biden's left but he's energized and he
has an approach to dealing with
Republicans that might be more appealing
but on the one on the other hand the
name recognition isn't really fully
there and I don't know the other
perspective is the way to challenge Joe
Biden most effectively would be
balancing being truly on the left as
some Define it and being more well known
so that would point to Someone Like
Bernie Sanders who is even older than
Joe Biden even though people want a
younger person rather than an older
person but but Bernie would be the
person who would be able to eke out the
most support my instinct is If today you
say to me Newsome enters or Bernie
enters I think if Bernie announces today
he immediately picks up more support
than Newsom would against Biden that's
my view right now
not enough to win not enough to win but
more support than you some would get
right personally I would love nibsum
because I love his energy and
hello is his adequence as well and and
his he and he provides the the amount of
tenacity that I think the Democrats
really need to to step up to the uh to
the competition against the uh
uh the Republicans I love newsom's
tenacity I love the way he says we need
to be ruthless and all of those things
right I don't know that he yet has the
name recognition to even have a shot in
Hell against an incumbent president but
in an open Democratic primary could be a
different story
right right okay thank you that's it for
me all right Thomas from Vietnam very
good to hear from you so great to hear
from anyone that called in and also
anyone who called in but wasn't able to
talk to me we will take calls again and
I so look forward to speaking with you
next time we'll take a quick break and
be right back
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get into the mailbag
also known as Friday feedback also known
as the Friday Feed Bag
I don't know you can email info
davidpackman.com
leave a YouTube comment send a tweet
whatever the case may be your commentary
might end up featured in this segment we
will start with William Sutherland who
suggested via a YouTube comment to my
entire audience people
go watch Jimmy Dore someone who talks
truth not this BS and you know what if
this comment resonates with you
I am not going to try to convince you
otherwise one of the things I'm actively
not going to do on the program
is try to convince people about why or
whether they should watch or listen to
me or anybody else if to you if you go
over to Jimmy dore's Channel and you say
you know it looks to me like Jimmy Dore
is telling the quote truth and David
pakman is quote lying
that's great
go watch Jimmy door leave me alone I'm
not gonna be offended whatsoever okay I
I would love for you to do that Marvin
whitler commented on YouTube
quote
to be a atheist you have to acknowledge
there is a God for you not to be live in
Therefore your wrong your not an atheist
this is painfully stupid
if I don't believe in purple unicorns
does that mean that I there must be a
purple unicorn out there somewhere for
me not to believe in it
no that doesn't make any sense
whatsoever this is the type of nonsense
that ends up becoming a meme and
repeated and repeated and repeated
and if you take one second to think
about it
you realize it doesn't make a shred of
sense whatsoever to be a atheist you
have to acknowledge there is a God
no you don't doesn't really make any
sense I'm sorry okay Grimace posted to
the subreddit about my book
recommendation waves of rancor and says
David mentioned this book on a show last
week I was able to hunt down a copy holy
cow reading this book is eye-opening it
was published in 99 and the stuff they
talk about how the far writer
indoctrinated is insane they still use
the same techniques today I highly
recommend it I would buy a used copy or
find a means of getting a less expensive
digital copy this is fantastic this
really you know how it's like you can
you can get anything right now you can
find any random book
this book is genuinely tough to get I
ended up getting a used hardcover copy
looks like an old school library book I
think it might have been a library book
at some point and I didn't I didn't
remember the book was from 99 I thought
it was even older if you want to trace
how right-wing media got to where it is
today and right wing indoctrination got
to where it is today
you have to understand how it started
and this book waves of rancor goes back
to the way in which talk radio
originally ended up on AM radio the
degree to which right-wing religious
broadcasters sucked up a bunch of the
licenses for broadcasting all the way
through and into Fox News if you really
want to understand how our media got to
where it is today such an important book
and I love that Grimace was able to uh
find a copy also from the subreddit Matt
lately
says does anybody else reflexively say
truth sensual or Lauren bobert I watched
too many of his meaning my videos that
the wrong pronunciations are permanently
stuck in my head yeah the same thing
happens to me sometimes when when Trump
goes at a speech and he says they should
really be investigating Biden and
Hillary and even Obama Obama I will
sometimes almost feel like Trump got it
wrong by saying Obama instead of Obama
they are they're extraordinarily meme
worthy uh little Snippets and I
apologize if now they're in people's
heads in that way okay also from the
subreddit this is from a user named cool
customer
this gets me back to do people watch
what I watched the videos before
commenting do people listen to what I
say before commenting I recently did a
segment about Bobby Kennedy Junior's
candidacy saying this guy's an anti-vaxx
dude he's using pro-putin talking points
no one should vote for him and yes I
once had dinner with him and we have
mutual friends
look at the posts that showed up on my
subreddit David shouldn't whitewash uh
Bobby Kennedy Jr I understand there's a
personal Progressive connection there
but in my opinion David shouldn't cover
for his anti-vaccine history he didn't
become anti-vaccine during the pandemic
he's been anti-vax since 2005.
in fact he runs one of the largest
vaccine disinformation campaigns
Children's Health defense uh he's done
an inordinate amount of damage to Public
Health
um
okay so anyway the point here is did you
even listen to what I had to say I
didn't whitewash it in fact what I said
was despite the fact that this is a
little awkward because I've met Bobby
Kennedy Jr and we had dinner ones and we
have friends in common
his candidacy is a disaster he's an
unmitigated anti-vaxxer he's going on TV
he went on Tucker before Tucker was
fired and used pro-putin talking points
this is a disaster and by the way Steve
Bannon loves the idea of Bobby Kennedy
running as a quote Chaos Agent and it's
all the nonsense I didn't whitewash
anything
in fact I said despite personal
connections I think that this campaign
is an absolute and total disaster so
please
criticize me for things I've said not
things I haven't said the Bobby Kennedy
candidacy is a disaster without a doubt
okay John uh commented on YouTube just
remember the same people who want to ban
clothing they don't think is appropriate
are almost always the same people who
wanted to ban masks during a worldwide
deadly pandemic it's more about their
personal feelings over those of anyone
else yeah this goes to this idea that
um Ben Shapiro talked about the idea of
banning people from wearing clothes that
don't align with the traditional clothes
worn by their gender and I explained it
makes absolutely no sense and then the
Department of Agriculture I believe it
was in Texas we talked about it last
week is looking to put in a policy where
you have to dress in accordance with the
traditional clothing of your gen it is
you know the same people who uh talk
about how great freedom is and Liberty
and government not getting involved in
people's lives are now saying we're
going to decide what you wear they are
the same to some degree they are the
same folks that were saying um uh no
masks band masks whatever
and then going to leave the masking to a
personal choice but not the clothing
we'll decide what clothing you can wear
but leave the masking to a personal
choice these aren't serious people
that's really at the end of the day the
most important thing to understand these
are not serious individuals who bring
real thought to the table they
reflexively will say whatever they think
at that particular moment is useful to
achieve whatever immediate goal they
have even if it conflicts with whatever
they said A week ago
a user sassy Nana
asks a really great question about these
ideas of sending homeless people to
encampments outside cities for
rehabilitation of different kinds sassy
Nana says how do you rehabilitate
a homeless single mother
who works full-time at Subway but can't
afford an apartment and of course that
is an absolutely accurate critique of
this idea that Trump has about we're
going to get them seen by doctors and
psychiatrists and we're going to get get
them off drugs and all these different
things
tons of homeless people
are working or very recently were
working and either way sending them
outside of a city will either make them
unable to continue working
or make it dramatically more difficult
for them to get a job anytime soon it's
a disastrous idea the homeless
encampment idea has a recent examples of
how it's failed and more distant in
history examples of how it's failed it's
inhumane the conditions always become
ridiculously humiliatingly bad
dangerously bad and the crowd cheers
whenever Trump brings it up so it is
very very scary stuff if you have
anything you want to say feedback on the
show criticisms praise whatever you can
email info davidpackman.com or leave a
comment on any of our various social
media platforms we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today the show
doesn't have to end right now if you're
not a member there's no more show until
next Monday if you are a member we have
the bonus show coming right up you can
sign up at joinpakman.com and make
absolute sure that you know the coupon
code indicted is available to you and I
think it's uh it's like a 50 discount
off of the cost of membership join
pacman.com see you on the bonus